let's start with some more economic news
and financial news yesterday we started
the show digging into some
uh more meaty economics and finance type
stories people seem to like it
so let's do it again we now have more
detail
about the proposed joe biden tax plan
now you might remember
that during a number of white house
press briefings
um jen saki the white house press
secretary
would repeat this line nobody making
under four hundred thousand dollars a
year
would pay any more under joe biden and
gensake was rightly confronted with the
question
is that four hundred thousand individual
or is that four hundred thousand
for a couple uh because typically there
are two different
sort of cutoffs for individuals versus
couples and gensake would weirdly say
it's for both which didn't make any
sense and at the time i called it out
and some of you got mad and said david
sir no no
it didn't make any sense now we have
more visibility
into what the actual policy is going to
be and so let's dig into it there's a
new report from cnbc
joe biden's proposed 39.6
top tax rate would apply at these income
levels now as a reminder what we're
talking about here is something really
uncontroversial just just so you
remember
we're talking about going back from 37
to 39.6
all of this debate about raising taxes
on the rich
what we're talking about is just going
back to a rate we previously had for top
earners which was 39.6 instead of
instead of 37
that's all we're talking about here uh
the rate would
affect this is the key part the rate
would affect
single individuals with a taxable income
of more than 452
700 a year and married couples filing
jointly
with income over five hundred and nine
thousand three hundred dollars according
to a budget proposal issued
friday also important to remember
the top rate is slated to increase to
39.6 percent
after 2025 even if congress doesn't pass
biden's proposal
so understand you know when we talk
about
truly progressive economic policy
and we look at some of the things they
have in northern europe
i have friends in the netherlands who
are are working
uh there and have told me about the the
tax structure
there we are here talking about
a disagreement between republicans and
democrats
most around the edges where we're saying
once you get to 450 000 a year in income
on everything you earn beyond that
because remember it's a marginal
tax marginal tax system should you pay
37
or 39.6 percent so let me give you an
example of how
relatively little of an impact this has
on people who would actually
pay it okay remember that because it's
marginal
up to 450 to 700 you pay what people
earning less than that pay
once you get to 452 700
a year you start paying 39.6 instead of
37. so imagine someone making one
million dollars a year
okay if you make a million dollars a
year
if on everything above 452
000 you go from paying 37
to 39.6 that's an extra 2.6 percentage
points
on that difference your total tax
from this big tax increase is
an increase of 10 900 for the year now i
have
you know i'm a big personal finance guy
maybe i'm a better saver or budgeter
than other people
if you're making a million dollars a
year gross
and ten thousand nine hundred dollars a
year in extra taxes
changes your lifestyle you're doing
something wrong you're not budgeting
correctly
you're not managing your finances
correctly okay when we talk about
uh paying an extra 2.6 percent on
the 547 thousand dollars that would be
subject to that top tax rate if that
materially changes your lifestyle in any
way
you are terrible with money and i'll be
honest you probably don't make a million
dollars a year to begin with
unless you you know are getting that
through some kind of inheritance or
whatever right
but if if you're like an entrepreneur
making a million dollars a year
you probably are good enough with your
money that you won't even notice
this extra ten thousand nine hundred
dollars a year in taxes that's under an
extra thousand dollars a month for
someone making a million bucks a year
so that is what we're talking about and
of course the reaction from many people
to this is going to be
why aren't we talking about a higher uh
rate for people making even more what
about as i've proposed
before many times don't we need a higher
bracket where okay it goes to 39.6 when
you get to 452 000 but
maybe at 1 million dollars a year in
income it goes to 42
maybe at 2 million a year in income it
goes to
46 these are the types of proposals that
have been outlined by some of the most
progressive members of congress
and we're like just barely even touching
the edges here
so this is what the debate is about and
importantly as the article reminds us
the trump tax cuts of 2017
which dropped that rate from 39.6 to 37
they automatically expire in 2025 if
congress does nothing
okay so i know we have a presidential
election in 2024
it may be consequential in many ways one
of those ways would be what does it do
to that top tax rate but
what we're talking about here it's
almost laughable right
like the debate right now is
should the rate for those making over
450k a year
go to from 37 now
and by now i mean like you know this
year next year
or should it not happen until 2025.
that's the big debate and i will never
understand
although people like jonathan height
have explained it to me i still don't
totally get it
why do people who make forty thousand
dollars a year care about this
the the you you've got people who make
thirty thousand forty thousand fifty
sixty seventy thousand dollars a year
even ninety or a hundred thousand
dollars a year going
crazy about how joe biden wants to
increase your taxes we're talking about
2.6 percentage points on people making
nearly half a million dollars a year or
more
and the outrage from these folks i don't
get now
somebody like jonathan height would say
what's going on here is it's not about
whether
joe the plumber making 400 i'm sorry
making 40 000
a year is actually going to pay more
personally
it's about whether he identified he or
she but i'm we're talking about joe the
plumber imaginary here
it's about whether joe deplo the plumber
joe diploma
joe the plumber believes that
this is a tax change that is on his team
or it's for someone else's team and we
saw it in 2010 with the tea party
the tea party uh a bunch of people
making very little money who were very
proudly and loudly
against tax increases for the very very
rich so
that's the situation we now have the
exact numbers from the joe biden
proposal and administration and um it
is shocking to me how many people don't
even understand that we have a marginal
tax system like i've met lawyers
who think that if the tax top tax rate
is 39.6 percent
if you make a million bucks a year you
pay 39.6
on all of your income when the reality
is you pay that only on the income
above that top tax threshold
disturbing that so many people seem not
to understand this but these are the
numbers we now have them
and we'll see what the reaction is from
the right one of our sponsors is
magic spoon breakfast cereal sweet and
delicious like the cereals we loved as
kids but without the sugar
and without the carbs magic spoon tastes
just like those sugary cereal brands we
know and love
but it's only 140 calories zero grams of
sugar
only four net carbs and packed with 13
to 14 grams of protein so it's perfect
for anyone following
a keto or low carb diet or just
anyone who wants to avoid sugar like me
you can choose from flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry
cinnamon or build your own variety box
if you don't love magic spoon as much as
i do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked
that is how much magic spoon believes in
their product
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video